more than 50 years ago I began my
studies at the Columbia School of
Architecture which occupies the floors
above the Avery library where we are now
it was there that I first learned about
drawing instruments using the set that
my father had bought second hand when he
first started to study engineering
drawing in 1918 but it wasn't really my
father who got me started on collecting
that was my design professor charles
rigger he invited the class over to his
spacious West End Avenue apartment
fatigue one afternoon the large dining
room that he had in that apartment
doubled as a library and an exhibition
space for his treasures some of which
were splendid sets of antique drafting
instruments they included the double
sized set that is now on display here at
Avery professor Rieger had bought that
set in Paris in 1937 it was probably
made originally for one of the many
industrial expositions that were held in
France during the second half of the
nineteenth century it's an interesting
set but it's not very practical for use
the ink would run right out of that huge
ruling pen a much more practical set
would be this one made by William Harris
on the ivory scale is his address
47 hi Hoban London from that address we
can tell that the set dates from 1799 to
1812 this set is 200 years old and yet
it still functions perfectly well and
it's not terribly different from the set
that I use to create architectural
drawings sets somewhat like this one and
larger sets in wooden boxes form a part
of the Avery collection of drawing
instruments
you